oh good that's the next element assume I
knew nothing about her soon should we
make something up hassium is an element
which I knew nothing about
but now I discover it's really much more
interesting than I thought we here in
the German state of Hesse er at the
institut GSI where hassium was first
made in 1984 cassia is the latin name
for this part of germany Hessert and
hence it is named after the place it was
discovered so down here we have the
accelerator that accelerated atoms of
iron to bang into a LED target to make
element 108 hassium element 108 is
actually in the same group of the
periodic table as iron that much I knew
when I first talked about it but what I
didn't realize is that the element has a
few atoms that are long enough leaved
that you can really do chemistry so once
the atom flies off from the back of the
target when it has been created you can
pass it through an atmosphere of oxygen
and make the oxides hassium tetroxide
hso4 and this iron the iron of this
molecule this oxide can then be followed
to see how volatile it is and compared
with osmium tetroxide osmium tetroxide
is a white solid which is quite volatile
it easily evaporates and you can show
that hassium tetroxide does not
evaporate quite so easily but it's
amazing this is an element only 40 atoms
have been made you can tell how its
oxide behaves osmium has one of the
highest melting points of any element
that's no
the people who make periodic tables
where you have a sample of each element
have great trouble melting osmium to
make the sample so it may be that
hassium would have an even a higher
melting point it could be that it's the
highest melting point element in the
periodic table but one would have to
make a lot more atoms than that if
you're good to find out what the melting
point was I think people may be able to
calculate it but the melting point
depends on the strength of the
interaction between the atoms and unless
you have quite a few atoms that's very
difficult to measure and quite a few
means many tens of millions because even
a small particle so-called nanoparticle
of metal can have quite different
properties from a large lump